Tristan Thompson's mom Andrea has died
a source tells E.T the NBA Pro traveled
to Toronto with his ex Khloe Kardashian
where a private funeral is scheduled the
source notes that Chloe her mom Kris
Jenner and her sister Kim Kardashian are
all expected to attend a separate Source
tells E.T Chloe was very close to
Tristan's mom adding that quote the
family will be first to support them
especially in this very difficult time
DMZ reports that Andrea suffered a heart
attack at home on Thursday she was
reportedly rushed to a local hospital
where medical experts tried to
resuscitate her but she didn't make it
Tristan has posted tons of photos with
his mom over the years including snaps
of Andrea with his kids including
daughter true whom he shares with Chloe
back in 2016 Tristan opened up about his
relationship with his mom sharing that
he spoke to her every day quote everyone
knows that my mom she's very dedicated
in taking care of her sons but at the
same time you need to make sure that
she's okay so I always try to make sure
that she's doing well too that's crucial